les combats se poursuivent à siviero
donesk cette grande ville du donbass
moscou y concentre son offensive et ses
soldats mais selon l'armée ukrainienne
une partie du territoire perdu aux mains
des russes a été reconquis
j'ai personnellement entendu de
nombreuses fois que ces vielles route de
ness qui était occupé que l'armée russe
l'avait complètement prise explique le
gouverneur mais ce n'est pas le cas les
russes occupent environ 70% du
territoire
nous avons repris environ 20% de celui
ci dit il
toujours dans le dos de basse la ville
de soldats régulièrement la cible de
tirs us tout ce matin l'appartement de
ces dames a été lourdement endommagée
par le souffle d'un bombardement renault
ce trio il si j'étais resté ici et que
je n'étais pas allé dans la cuisine je
ne serai plus envie assure-t-elle
les batailles acharnées se poursuivre
ailleurs au pays près de desa un avion
ukrainien transportant des armes et des
munitions a été abattu c'est ce que le
ministère russe de la défense indique
aujourd'hui
faisant le point sur les dernières
opérations
sur le plan diplomatique
emmanuel macron est sévèrement critiquée
par kiev il a une nouvelle fois répété
qu'il ne fallait pas humilier la russie
question de préserver les canaux de
communication des propos mal reçus
pendant ce temps le français bruce fait
toujours craindre une crise alimentaire
mondiale
l'inquiétude est grandissante
particulièrement en afrique puisque le
continent et porte la forte majorité de
ces céréales d'ukraine mais elles sont
paralysés en raison de la guerre plus
aucun navire ne quitte le pays vladimir
poutine promet de faciliter le passage
de ces denrées à condition que les ports
soient des mines et par kiev ici et me
lemieux radio canada montréal